-Our next guest has his comedy
special, "Perfectly Stupid,"
available now at
perfectlystupid.com.
Please welcome the very funny
Kurt Braunohler, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello. Thank you.
So, I have two kids,
which is so much more than one.
I don't know if I like
who I am with two kids.
I love the kids.
But, recently,
I screamed at my entire family
at the dinner table, "I don't
care if everyone's crying.
I'm eating."
I don't want to be that man.
And when I had one kid,
if someone asked me,
"Hey, should I have kids?",
I was like, "Yeah."
But now, when I have two kids,
if someone's like,
"Should I have kids?",
I'm like, "Don't talk to me.
I have 15 minutes to
drink this vodka soda
before going to bed,
because every minute
that he sleeps
that I don't sleep,
he gets stronger than me!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I want to be a good dad.
I'm trying.
I'll tell you a story.
There's a gas station
near my house.
It has a small, handwritten sign
on one of the pumps that says,
"Please replace nozzle to pump
before driving away with it."
And I thought that was funny.
You know, I laughed at
all these idiots
who were driving away with
the pump still in their car.
And so, when I drove away with
the pump in my car...
I was bashful,
a little embarrassed,
you might say.
I didn't even know
I did it, okay?
Hopped in my car, blasting
my meditation app, and just
took off, yanked it
right out of the thing,
and immediately pulled an
illegal four-lane U-turn.
All the oncoming traffic
was like...
[ Imitates horns honking ]
And I was like,
"Oh, screw you, nerds!
It's a U-turn!"
I gave them all
the middle finger,
meanwhile spewing gasoline
across the street.
And then I made a right and
I got on an even bigger highway,
started going very fast.
And, mind you, I have a tail.
Just...
And a big white pickup truck
pulls up next to me
and starts honking at me,
and I was like, "It's a U-turn!"
And he's like,
"Roll your window down."
I was like, "What?"
He was like, "You drove
away with the pump in your car."
And I was like, "Oh, you drove
away with the -- Aah!
So I did."
And then I was very embarrassed.
I didn't know what to do.
I'm on a highway,
so I just pulled over
to the side of the road.
And he pulled over, too.
And then I got out of my car,
and he got out of his car.
And, mind you,
I'm deeply embarrassed.
It's essentially like
I just crapped my pants,
and he, like, followed me
into the bathroom like,
"Hey, did you
crap your pants, man?
Hey, how much
crap is in your pants?
Hey, why you think
you crapped your pants earlier?"
And I was like,
"What do you want?"
And he said, "Do you need help?"
And I realized,
I had a choice as dad.
You know, I could act like men
have acted for millennia.
I could lash out like
a wounded animal.
Or I could be vulnerable
and admit, "Yes, I screwed up
and I do need help."
And so I looked
at this man offering
this olive branch of help
and I said, "No!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then I got in
my car and drove away.
And I -- You know,
at first, I looked at the car
and I realized,
"Oh, I have gas --
I pulled it out of my car
and I was like,
"This is filled with gas still."
What would be very
useful would be a pickup truck,
but that guy just -- I just told
him to go screw himself.
So then I had to walk with it
in my arms along the highway
like a big dead snake
back to where
both gas-station managers are
standing outside waiting for me.
And then I just laid it
at their feet.
And I was like,
"What do we do now?"
And they're like,
"We don't know.
There's no form for this, pal."
Turns out, it costs $350,
which is honestly a lot less
than I expected.
And you know what?
They're designed to
just pop right off,
so you can just do it.
It doesn't matter.
You can just do it.
Honestly, if you turned it
into a comedy bit,
maybe you'll get on
"The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
♪♪
-Wow! Uh-huh.
Come on. That's unbelievable.
Kurt Braunohler!
Kurt Braunohler --
"Perfectly Stupid"
is available at
perfectlystupid.com.
We'll be right back, everybody.